this is not a surprise there's been a
lot of talk in the marketplace about
possible strategic restructuring sales
and things what do we know about what's
going on at Twitter we don't know all of
the details yet but what's being
reported right now as Alex mentioned is
that there's been early expressions of
interest from several technology
companies including Google and including
sales force you know what CNBC is saying
at this point is that a sale is not
imminent but that we might see something
by year-end and obviously a lot of
things can change over the next couple
of months and as you mentioned twitter
is no stranger to takeover speculation
we did a study earlier this month that
found twitter has jumped more than four
point eight percent one out of every six
trading day so far this year I mean that
is a crazy amount of takeover
speculation especially for a company
Twitter size so Twitter was a Darwin
grew up and had enormous growth over 30
time and then that gross started to
flatten out some and became a little
less favorite so at this point what does
a tech company see in Twitter put
yourself in their shoes what are they
looking for there's still a very
significant user base even if that user
base isn't growing as much as it once
was there's still a huge base of people
that use this for you know daily things
whether that's journalist or whether
that's people looking for news on
certain events and that has value to
tech companies those are valuable
eyeballs and you know maybe in the hands
of somebody who has a little bit more
experience dealing with advertisers you
might be able to make this a little bit
more profitable get more out of those
eyeballs earlier today that was
interesting the stock was down Mark
Mahaney over to RBC downgraded the stock
exceeds 25% downside because advertisers
are not getting the bang for their buck
they're seeing less return on those ad
dollars that's a huge issue especially
when competitors like Google and
Facebook are like laughing up the ad
revenue it certainly isn't it i think
that raises the question could somebody
be executing the advertising strategy
better could somebody like Facebook
which you know gets lots of money from
advertising or somebody like Google
somebody with more experience in this
area be doing a better job of figuring
out how to make these advertisers happy
in that respect it echoes a little bit
the Yahoo deal with AOL because AOL has
a lot of ad tech and they're really good
at that and Yahoo still is a lot of
eyeballs now obviously Twitter is newer
in the tooth it's not as long in the
tooth as you
who is but is is this something that
Salesforce could afford to buy do you
know because Google certainly has the
money they've got the cash sure I mean
well Salesforce was looking at LinkedIn
so we know they've thought about doing
big deals in the past twitter is not
cheap when we were looking at it earlier
this month it is still very expensive
even after the stock has fallen so far
this year I mean I haven't updated the
numbers yet but earlier this month we
when we ran the data looking at the
premium that Microsoft paid for LinkedIn
Twitter would be crazy expensive at
about 19 billion dollars and they're
very high ebit evaluation relative to
other deals in the industry so this
isn't going to be a cheap deal but you
never know tech companies are willing to
do big expensive deals all the time so
we'll see and Salesforce has been very
acquisitive they haven't been very shy
and buying things that's for sure so
when do you expect to hear something on
this I mean if there's something here
that's a long will it take yeah the best
thing you know I think we'll have to
wait and sort of see what comes out of
this you know it seems like it's very
early stage at this point based on the
details that are currently being
reported out there and so will sort of
have to see what happens the other
question is does Twitter want to sell I
mean it's not exactly trading at peak
valuation right now is this sort of an
admission of defeat if you sell when
your stock is trading at these levels
and what sort of valuation is going to
make the founders and that's always the
question what's the price everybody's
willing to sell at the right price the
right questions would be high enough
exactly exactly right